校長の理論の土台となってるのが動物行動学と授教と仏教と大和魂っていうところで、
そう、そう、
大和魂についてそろそろ話が聞きたいっていうコメントがたくさんあったので、
そうやね。ただね、長かかるよ、大和魂は。まず最初のだけ抑えとこうか。大和魂の定義できるかな?できんやろ。ま、で、大和魂が大事だという人はいくらでもおるんだ。
[音楽]
だけど大和って何なのと言うとさあそれは
なるん。あれがいかんのやな。だから
リベラルに言わせると大和魂は消しからん
。なぜならば戦争を起こしたからってだけ
だけどそれはヤ和魂の使い方やないか大体
大和魂で戦争起こしたわけやないやろ。
魂って言うと、ま、反対派の意見としては、ま、特攻体とかのそういう風に使われたから危険なんじゃないかっていうのが主な意見だと思うんですけど。
あれは愛国心の方やろな。大和魂の中にもあるけど別に愛国心があるのは大和魂だけやないよ。で、そいつを利用した人がおるわけやないかね。だから利用の仕方が良かったか悪かったかの問題であってよく最初の頃言ったろは全であるな。
カードの使い方ソフトによって悪になるん
だ。自動車は全だけどその扱い方が悪いと
事故を起こす悪やないか。ヤ和魂は全だ
けどその使い方によって悪になったことが
あったかもしれんなというのはこれあれで
もそうやろナチズムなんかでも愛国心を
悪い方に使っちまったわけやろ。そういう
そのよく考えようよと。あれはアメリカが
言ったことであってさ。アメリカにとって
大和魂というのは非常に都合の悪い精神論
ない。何しろ明治時代あの頃一斉に東与
アジアが文明化したわけやろ。ところが
欧米に対抗できるほど伸びたのは日本だけ
やないか。だからなぜ伸びたかをずっと
調べとるんだ。要するに大和魂があった
から伸びたんだと。だから今せっかく
やっつけて日本が0マイナスまで持って
いったのにこのまま大和魂を残しておくと
どんどんどんどん今から伸びていってまた
アメリカに向かってくるぞとそういうこと
が起こらんようにしとかんといかん。だ
から大和湿にしたのはアメリカやないか。
そいつを朝新聞がわわわと言って宣伝して
前は自分たちが戦争を起こした負けたくせ
に今度は戦争反対だったのに無理やりああ
いう記事を欠かされたんだって言い出した
んやね。で、大和魂反対、大和魂が戦争を
起こすという大和魂はいかんのだという
ことを大宣伝したのが朝日やないか。
そいつはアメリカの言った通りのことを
言ったに過ぎんのであって彼らの考えでは
なかったんやからあの時に朝日がよく言っ
とったのは自分たちは大本迎発表ばっかり
を無理やりにあの報道させられたと。だ
から確かにあの時は間違ったけど自分たち
のせいじゃないって言い出したんやね。
同じ人間がGHの発表をそのまま垂れ流し
たんだ。
そういう新聞、朝日、特に朝日の情けなさがね、大和魂定ということを起こさしたんだ。
え、大和魂の定義っていうのは?
それを考えようよ。大和魂は何かも知らずに否定したらいかん。何かも知らずに肯定してもかん。だから大和魂とは何か。これがはっきり分かるようにしようや。チートは考えろよ。どうもうその特に文化系というのはものを考えん癖がついとるやろ。言われた通りの考えを持つ。
それはあんたの考えじゃない。他の人の
考えだ。その人が善意か悪意感によって
あんたも善か悪になっちまう。
ヤ和魂の定義覚えときよ。まず精神から
言わんといかんよね。精神とは何か?
ヤ和魂は精神だからね。精神の定義は行動
のプログラム。その精神によって行動する
んだ。だから精神が全なら行動も全になる
。これの非常にありがたいのはね、逆も
また真なりなんよ。行動したら精神が
できる。善なる行動。正しい行動をしたら
正しい精神ができる。だから行動によって
精神を作る。これが日本のあり方。
あるいは中国もそう、え、インドもそうな
んだ。だから正しいとは何かから入って
いって、その正しい結果が出るのが正しい
精神、正しい行動。正しい行動のことを義
という義と人は義だ。義というのは正しい
行動のことなんだ。だから義を行えば
正しい精神ができるんだ。申しに書いて
あるやろ。義を行いて生ずるものにして
遅いてこれを取るものにあらざるなり。
ずっと正しい行動をしてみろ。そうしたら
ば正しい精神が出来上がるから。で、遅い
てこれを取るものにあらざるなりというの
は勉強しとってだめよ。
つかないな。精神は身につけないと意味がない。そういうことやね。だから偏札はダメなんだ。覚えるばっかりで行動しないからやね。偏主修催なんか目指すんじゃない。行動から精神を作っていく。
[音楽]
長精神の定義から
回大和魂の定義のとこに戻ってもいいですか?
大和魂の定義も言ったよね。義を行う精神論。正しい行動をする精神論が大和魂。
[音楽]
さっきほらちょっと愛国心の話が出たじゃ
ない。愛国心って悪いものか?愛国心が
1番大事なんじゃないの?そいつを愛国心
はěしカらんと言い出したの朝日やろ。
国旗もあげるな、国家も歌うなと言って
特に学校で国家歌うのは消しからん言って
みんなやめさせたやねえか。国旗系用
とんでもない戦争を起こすて言い出した。
嘘やろ。そういう嘘を平然と言って
のけれるのがリベラルなんだ。で、どう
なった?今の状態も愛国の欠除から起こっ
とるやないか。
愛国のある人たち、戦前に教育を受けた人
たちやね、あの人たちがゼロより下に
下がっちまった日本を世界1にしちまった
やないか。で、それを受け継いだのが我々
。俺から始まるんだ。戦後最初の小学生だ
からな。我々はそれを受け継いで愛国否定
の教育を受けて世界1だったのは今38位
やろ受継ぐだけの能力がなかったんだ。
全部教育やでGHの陰謀に安引っかかった
ん安っかった主役が朝新聞やないか。え魂
っていうのがあったからこそ戦後に復興
できたっていう。おだから特攻隊がどうの
かの言っとったけど特攻隊に行く人が俺は
明日だからそのうち後続くからなという
ことをみんな残る人がいる。その時に死な
ずに戦後の日本を守ってくれって言っとる
わね。だから言われた方は寸でのとこで
自分は死ななかった。死に損なったていう
はね。だから命を戦後の日本の復興に
かけるに復興さしちまってしかも世界一に
しちまったやろ。
これが愛国心和魂がえているっていうのはどういう点から他に言えるんですか?
日本の歴史をずっと眺めてみて本当に世界に誇るべき時代っていうのが何回もあるんだ。まず第
[音楽]
が縄文時代だ。縄文時代っていうのはみんな原始的な古いダメな時代なんで教えられとる。
1000年平和が続いたんやで。
世界中のどこができるんや、そんなこと。
今の我々にできるかできやしないやろ。
だったらなぜ縄文時代、縄文がそんなこと
ができたのか解明すりゃええやないか。だ
もただ1つや。精神論が正しかった。精神
論が食い違っとるとアラブとイスラエルや
ん。あれ何千年戦っとるんだ。終わりが
ないやないか。あの俺中平和がないよね。
いつまでってもからもしアラブと
イスラエルが共通の精神論を持っとったら
もう両方平和になっとるわさ。正しい精神
論を持っとったらね。だから宗教はダめ。
正しくない。相手を認めないからね。同じ
ように哲学もダめ。哲学なんてた5万と
あるんや。どれが正しいかわからんやない
か。もし正しい哲学があったら全部そこに
集約するはずやろ。これが哲学ですという
ものが1つあったらええ。
正しければけどみんな正しくないからあんなにもうむぞうじうじやとあるやないか。大和魂は宗教と哲学ではないんですか?
[音楽]
ええ、あれは科学ですよ。そうやってできてきたものなんだ。どういう風にしてできてきた?
縄文時代から
本能的行動をしとってうまくいっとった。それが少しは理性的な行動をするようになるとうまくいかなくなるやろ。その時にまた本能的行動に引き戻す。
これが正しい精神論だっていうやつがおるん誰やと思う?
リーダー?
リーダーだってリーダーの素失があるからそれが巫女なんだ。あれみたいな卑というのは神の声を聞けるの。その神の声を聞いて判断する。
神の声っていうのは宗教ではないんですか?
神の声というのは本能のことだ。授教だってそれでできとる。仏教だってそれでできとるやね。
本能のことを分かりやすくする表面
本能の声を聞くことができるのが巫女なんだ。だからなんかのあれは与えられるやろ。政治的名題がポンとあって例えばどっかの王様がどうしようっつって巫に相談に行くんだ。巫やって捨てり状態になってあれはね消しとるんだ。理性を消したら本能の声が聞こえてくるんだ。本能で判断してこうしろという。
[音楽]
これが神の声だって言うわけで、王様はその通りやればええ。これが再生一致。
再生一致。
政治と治が一致するとまくんだところがだんだんおかしな。神の声の危険巫女が出てくるやないか。当然のことながら神の声だと言って金もらっと人に有利な答えを出したりそれでおかしなってきてダメになっちゃう。本物やったらば正しい答えを出しる。教中国の鏡教っていうのがあるやろ。
あれもそうなんやで。今通りの答えを出せばええんだ。それが液者な。
[音楽]
大和魂の義を行う精神論っていう部分についてもう少し伺ってもいいですか?
うん。正しい行動をする。で、そのための精神を養う。身つける。で、養ってみたらそれは本能論だったんだ。本能通りの答えを出せばいいところがね。それが難しいやないか。人間は坊産なんかがトレーニングをするに本能のね。
[音楽]
で、本能のトレーニングをして、本能の声
を聞く。これがね、公案って呼ばれとる
やろ。問題を出されてそれに対する答えを
出す。その答えが本能論ができるように
なったら自分の本能を読むことができる
ようになっとるわけ。ところが今な、もう
修行がめんどくさいもんであれがあるわけ
。イチな答えが書いてあるわけで、そいつ
を暗記しといて偉い人から問題出されたら
と答える。だからもうダめ。
正しいが分からんようになっとる法さがね。
大和魂が科学っていう部分について伺いたいんですけど、
他の精神論も世界中にある中で
はい。
なんで大ヤ和魂が最も科学的だっていう風に考えてるんですか?
実績があるからさ。まず
1番の実績はその縄文時代のあれだね。
1万2000
連の平和というそいつを成し遂げた世界中どこもできんやろ。そういうことは。しかも戦争なしでやっとるやろ。
ローマが3000年続いた言ってあれは
もう武力で他を抑えつけたから平和やった
わけやろ。そんなイチな方法やないんだ。
近頃では江戸時代だ。江戸時代がダメな
時代だったというのはあれは明治政府の
身分であって総戦とあいつはクーデタや
からね。明らかにクーデタの正当性が
なくなるやないか。から江戸時代というの
はとんでもない時代だったもんで俺たちが
ちゃんとした時代に変えてやったんだぞと
いうそれを言いたいもんで江戸時代はダメ
な時代だったって言っとるわけところがね
江戸の末期に鎖国が溶けてヨーロッパの
いわゆる文化人がたくさん日本に来とる
わけよ。その文化人が共通しているのは
日本が世界一の国だって言っとるんや。
そん中で有名なのはあれやな、
シュリーマンやね。トロイの遺跡を発掘し
た。そいつはね、今でも読めるから
シュリーマン旅行機深日本っていうのが
あるわ。あれ呼んでみてこら。ベタ面にし
とるで日本ここに最高の国があったんだと
。エルドラドってね。エルドラドがあった
んやと。なぜエルドラドかと言うと世界中
探してもこれほど幸福な顔をした国民はい
ないって言うんや。国中がみんな幸福に
なっとる。政治の目的は国民を幸福にする
ことやろ。達成されとるじゃん。どうして
そんなことができる?あの時政治に使っ
とったのは武士道。武子というのはヤ和魂
を道にしたもの。だから大和魂が科学で
あったからそいつを使うとちゃんとした
結果が出るんだ。正しい結果が。で、
幸福内さらに彼がびっくりするのはこれ
ほど貧乏な国がどうして幸福になれるんや
。ヨーロッパ人というのは金がないと物で
幸福になる国民だから貧乏では幸福に
なれんのや。日本人というのは金がなくて
も幸福になれるにどっちがええのよ。当然
金がなくても幸福になれる方に決まっとる
じゃん。だから日本というのは世界一の国
やってね。そいつをヨーロッパの精神論を
入れ、思想を入れ、文明を入れたら日本は
不幸になっちまった。物欲の塊になっ
ちまったやろ。そんな歴史を持ちながら
先祖を持ちながら大和魂を否定するやつが
あるか。
縄文時代から江戸時代から、ま、現代まで
大和魂っていうのはどのようにどういう
ものとして受け継がれてきたんです。同じ
民族だから同じ精神使っとったのよ。宮崎
の漫画の中の物の姫、あれは時代が
ちょっとよくわからんけど、あの中でその
ブラブを追い出される場面があったやない
か。最初の方にあいつは悪いことしてない
けどブラックのためにならんのやね。変な
物の毛にやられとるもんでね。で追い出さ
れる。そういう判断を巫女がしたい。あん
時もおばあさんの巫女がやったわね。だ
けどそれができたんだから言い悪いじゃ
なしにそのブラクにとって群れにとって
プラスになるかマイナスになるかで人間を
追い出したり殺したりしたんやね。
村分にしたりで平和が保てるんじゃ流みたいに悪いやつばっかりやもんであの法律で縛り上げんとしょうがないというそういう国とは違うんやみんながいい人間なんやね
日本の国民性というかそういう民族特有の精神っていうのは例えばどんなものがありますか?
その中でね
番大事なのはね和なんよ消徳大使が和を持ってなすれはねとなすやないん
や、輪を持って遠としとなせない。誰でも
知とるよね。どう使う?あんな天才の言っ
たことだから正しいんだ。使わにゃん。宝
の持ちれやろ。どうやって使っとる?使っ
てないよね。むしろ現場の人間というのは
思って遠としとなを使っとるんだ。実際の
現場を動かす時にね。で、それが使えた
ところは伸びていくわ。
で、アメリカもどうやらそれに気がついた
んやか。日本は団体にすると怖いぞと。だ
から団体にしないようにしないように
いろんな政策をやってきたやないか。成列
してはいかんとかお祭りをなくしてしまっ
たやないか。これみんなバカよね。お祭り
を地方のお祭りをみんななしにしちまった
わね。あれまとまるからいかんというわけ
よ。この頃また復活したやろ。うちの近く
なんかものすごい復活しとるわな。滑って
のお祭りが昔通りに戻ってきとる。
おかしいと思ったみんな。そういう時代に
朝日はトチ感なことを平気でまだ言っとる
んだ。だからいかんのや。あそこはな日本
を潰そう潰そうとしとる。アメリカの意を
受けてやね。
はというのはまたゆっくり説明するけども
これこそが日本を偉大にした精神なんや。
和を作る。で、大和魂の中にを作るという
ものがあるんだ。精神の中にそういうもの
が入ってる。だから日本は和を作るのが
得意ないや。近頃ではね、何年前やったか
なシコジャパンよ。なでシコジャパンが
決勝戦でアメリカを破って世界一になった
やないか。あの時にアメリカわけわからん
。で、ワンバックってあのアメリカの
キャプテンやったね。あいつがね破ったん
や。要するにテクニックはアメリカが上
だった。体力もアメリカが上だった。それ
なのに日本が勝った。そこが素晴らしいん
だって言っとったわ。プラスアルファが
あったなっていうことやね。で、あれが
アメリカ人の偉いとこやで。すぐにそいつ
を見つけて自分たちもそれを身につける。
それをやられちまったもんで。あれ以降
日本はアメリカに勝てない。体力も上、
テクニックも上でさらにプラスアルファも
同等になったらもう勝てんわね。ところが
日本はどうした?なんで勝ったか分からん
。だから勝った理由を調べようともせん
勝ってカブトの王閉めよって言われとった
やないか。そんなもんどうでもええんだ。
自分たちが何で買ったかわからんねん。
これこういうとこがいかんのやな。昔を
大事にしない。うん。もう消徳大使に
帰りゃええやないか。わなんだとことが
すぐわかる。で、日本の歴史を探っていく
とそういう場面がいっぱいあるんだ。
チートはな自分の国に誇りを持って愛国だ
。で、自分たちの先祖がやってきたことを
絵か自分たちが日本を大きくさけないんだ
。長いことかかって歴史の上でこうやって
生き延びて大きくなってきたんだ。西洋に
劣教にも支配されず。そういう国民性を
我々は持ってる。大和魂についてもっと
知りたいってなった時にどういう本を読ん
だりとかどういうことを勉強したらいい
みたいなものありますか?ない。自分で
考えていけさっきの議を行う精神論という
だけをヒントにしてどうしたらええかぞと
自分で考えてくんや。
考えれんのやったら地区に失敗しとるん。
[音楽]
まず何から何について考えたらいいと思いますか?
あ、それ実績について考えていきええんよ。だから特にね、今の言ったは、これは和の結果だというものを探していきゃええんだ。ずっとね。そしたらだんだん分かってくるから。それと授教と仏教で理論付けられとるから大本魂も授教と仏教をなくせないかんよ。読んだってわからんやろ。
[音楽]
中身がはっきり分かって正しく解釈してその上で大和魂について考えるんや。宗教仏教素晴らしいだけど大和魂はもっと素晴らしい。一旦今回の動画ではここまでで
ある程度系統打点わからんよね。
とはセミナーなんかでもよく大和魂のお話をされてると思うのでもし興味がある人は概要欄からセミナーの方を見ていただけると
セミナーもポツポツやからね。
からもうやろうと思ったら本格的に大和魂だけの講座を設けないかんわね。それで
番いかんのはね、先生がおらんね。みんな大本ってなんか知らんのよね。
校長的に1
番身につけてると思われる方は例えばどんな人がいますか?
いや、俺やないか。他の人もろでもないよね。特に道が大事だ言ってみあ、そうですか。
[音楽]
て道って何です?言うたらさあ、それはなあ、みんなこう知的に優れた人が先生やるんやろうけど優れてないわね。
また別の動画で大和魂については詳しくやってきたと思い
ね。ヤ魂ってちゃんとしっかりとやろうよ。
はい。
それさえできりゃな、もうこの目的達成や。俺の話のね。
ありがとうございました。
はい。
[音楽]